how you doing Adam good how was Mexican
you like just got back from Mexican got
just got back from Mexico it was a
fantastic experience the the people
could not have been nicer yeah and you
know we weren't sure because of the
context of everything and they really
wanted to know they wanted reassurance
that many many many people in America
and that's what I kept telling them
really loved Mexico and loved the
Mexican people yes and don't be
dissuaded or disheartened too much by
what you're hearing from certain people
by like the main [ __ ] I am so sorry
that's okay your little nickname for
Andy does not run shared with everyone
yeah
did you have you been to Mexico yeah I
was there like ten years ago I worked on
a movie in Mexico City mm-hmm so is
there for like a few weeks it was such a
great city
yes it's got 22 and a half million
people in it it's got more museums than
I think and I don't know I think it's
Harris yeah it's what it's a culturally
incredible City and the people or really
I got sick did you get sick when you
know everyone says oh you know you might
get sick yeah you know and so I was I
think I got a cold at one point what I
didn't get I didn't get the traditional
yeah would unless you get a cold out of
your butt I don't think it was a
butthole okay well then yeah you got
sick I did get it was sneezing
constantly out my ass
you're right that's what I had diarrhea
on my Mexican sneeze s yeah I when I was
there I was like priding myself I was
the only person not getting sick for the
longest time and then towards the end of
the trip for whatever reason I have no
idea
I ordered sushi from room service
in Mexico City sushi room service Mexico
City yeah and I ate it and within hours
was very sick that's what happened yes I
know if you've had this experience I did
this once where I don't know if you
remember the sandy but we went to Salt
Lake City to shoot something this is for
the 2002 Olympic time in Salt Lake City
and like a restaurant that mostly just
serves beef and stuff like that and I
didn't even look at the menu
I was busy it was been a long day
shooting I just said I'll have the
lobster
well and they were like the lobster and
I was like get it for me I'm no Bryan
yeah
and they brought me a lobster that was
blue gray I think it had voted for
Truman Lord it was the oldest Lobster in
the world and I remember trying to cut
into it and like rubber bands run out of
it and then I thought its Salt Lake City
it's completely landlocked this lobster
had to crawl across the desert I mean it
had been traveling for weeks did you eat
it and get sick I was really proud I ate
it I don't think I could get sick
because there's nothing no organism
could have live in there right was right
exactly it was so old so so you you I
got sick and I remember this this is I
just remembered this today that I was
sick and so a doctor came to my River
production sent a doctor to give me a
shot right and he said unfortunately
sorry I need to give you a shot in your
rear ends and so I had never had this
shot in my rear end before but I guess
what you do is you just kind of pull
down the back of your pants and they
give you a little bit yeah right yeah
but I
I was sick and I like got out of bed my
wife was there with us and it got out of
bed and I just like stood up and pulled
it I pulled my pants all the way down
and then just got on the bed like this
and this poor doctor who's like oh no no
no no no did you give them the light
right so my wife was like no no no no
you can just you can just kind of pull
them in and so we did it and he left and
she was like did you like what were you
asking for there I don't know I think we
all know it was happening there
you